[Música]
las fuerzas rusas continúan su avance
hacia aquí mientras siguen atacando las
proximidades del puerto de odessa hay
particular temor por un bombardeo sobre
esta ciudad al ser un punto clave para
la cadena de suministros básicos en
ucrania
la guerra en este país podría afectar el
funcionamiento de la estación espacial
internacional
rusia alega que con las sanciones
internacionales tendría que dejar de
enviar los componentes que mantienen en
órbita la instalación
todo listo en colombia para las
elecciones legislativas de este domingo
16 de los escaños del congreso one para
víctimas del conflicto con la extinta
guerrilla de las farc en la misma
jornada se llevan a cabo consultas
interpartidistas para elegir a algunos
candidatos presidenciales
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornada soy
valentina torres sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos en ucrania reino
unido según reino unido- las tropas
rusas se acercan a kiev al tiempo que
continúa el asedio a la ciudad de
mykolaiv el último punto estratégico
desde donde podrían lanzar su ataque al
puerto de odessa entretanto continúa el
éxodo de ucranianos más de 2.6 millones
han tenido que huir del país y se
enfrentan a riesgos como la trata de
personas que afecta sobre todo a las
mujeres y a los niños en el continente
europeo alva santana nos cuenta más
con cientos de miles de personas huyendo
de ucrania muchos países europeos entre
ellos fronterizos como polonia o rumanía
se han volcado con los refugiados muchos
particulares ofrecen desde alojamiento y
comida gratis hasta propuestas de
trabajo una práctica que también implica
riesgos
hay muchas propuestas peligrosas de
diferentes personas pueden ofrecernos
ayuda gratis para llegar a cualquier
país
[Música]
me dijo que tengo que comunicarme
únicamente con gente oficial del tipo y
es que la onu advierte del gran peligro
al que están expuestos los migrantes
concretamente a prácticas como tráfico
humano y sexual especialmente las
mujeres y los niños
[Música]
esta mañana hemos encontrado a tres
hombres intentando meter a un grupo de
mujeres en una furgoneta no puede decir
al cien por ciento que estuvieran
intentando reclutar las para tráfico
sexual pero cuando nos acercamos se
pusieron nervios
y la trata de personas es una grave
violación de los derechos humanos y
tienen muchas formas de explotación
desde la prostitución forzada hasta la
esclavitud en europa la forma más común
de explotación es la sexual tres cuartas
partes de las víctimas son mujeres y una
de cada cuatro son niños razón por la
que las autoridades recomiendan a los
refugiados anotar las placas de todos
los autos a los que suben
cuando comparas solo eliges lo que
parece ser menos peligroso
no tienes otra opción pese a las
precauciones este es un riesgo elevado
para los migrantes que muchas veces
dependen de desconocidos para llegar a
su destino final
y las consecuencias de la guerra incluso
se sienten en el espacio el jefe de la
agencia espacial rusa roscósmos advirtió
que la estación espacial internacional
podría caer a la tierra argumentando que
dejaría de enviar las naves espaciales
que la mantienen en órbita debido a las
sanciones contra rusia
este vídeo publicado por la agencia
espacial rusa roscósmos muestra el
segmento ruso de la estación espacial
internacional desprendiéndose dejándolo
a merced de la atracción gravitatoria de
la tierra el jefe de roscósmos dice que
occidente se arriesga a que esto ocurra
y afirma que la órbita de la estación no
lo llevaría a caer sobre rusia sino en
otro lugar sobre quién podría caer la
estación espacial internacional de 500
toneladas la población de otros países
incluidos los dirigidos por perros de la
guerra deberían pensar en el precio de
las sanciones que iniciaron contra
roscósmos se trata de una amenaza vacía
o una preocupación seria rusia es
responsable de mantener la estación a
flote y es cierto que si cayera a la
tierra no toda el ya se quemaría en la
atmósfera pero rusia también es
responsable de apartar la estación
espacial internacional de los desechos
espaciales si deja de cooperar podría
estar poniendo en peligro la vida de
tres de sus cosmonautas que están a
bordo
en cualquier caso empresas como northrop
grumman y space six están interviniendo
para asegurarse de que la estación en
órbita y sea maniobrable pero para la
nasa el riesgo no es solo una caída
repentina a la tierra sino una triste
pérdida de colaboración científica
internacional
sería muy difícil para nosotros operar
por nuestra cuenta la estación es una
asociación internacional que se creó con
dependencias conjuntas que es lo que
hace que sea un programa tan increíble
'mazinger el desmantelamiento controlado
de la estación espacial internacional
está previsto para 2031 cuando se
dirigirá hacia una tumba acuática en el
océano pacifico expertos aseguran que al
menos el 60 por ciento de las
exportaciones de aceite de girasol
provenientes del mar negro están
retrasadas tras la invasión a ucrania
ucrania y rusia son los principales
exportadores mundiales y ahora el mundo
entero está luchando para compensar esas
faltas esto mientras el precio del
aceite continúa aumentando campos como
éste están profundamente arraigados en
la historia de ucrania el país es uno de
los principales exportadores mundiales
de aceite de girasol ucrania produce más
de la mitad del suministro mundial
mientras que rusia representa un tercio
esas exportaciones están ahora bajo
amenaza tras la guerra en ucrania
teniendo escasez consumidores en españa
están guardando reservas me dado cuenta
que hay mucha gente que lleva por la
calle en curso bombonas de 5 mililitros
para enfrentar las compras por pánico
los supermercados empezaron a imponer un
límite en las compras aquí cada cliente
solo puede comprar una botella de 5
litros el 70% de las exportaciones
ucranianas pasan por el mar negro y el
tráfico allí está en un punto muerto
causando estragos en las cadenas de
suministros este experto dice que los
efectos de la guerra se mantendrán los
agricultores plantan semillas en abril y
no sabemos cómo se verá esto ahora
suficiente mano de obras habrán
suficientes semillas para plantar
suficientes girasoles para el próximo
año con la incertidumbre sobre el futuro
del suministro los precios se inflaron y
los productores franceses de papas
fritas también sienten el impacto
este contenedor tiene aceite de girasol
se vende a una fortuna mil litros
cuestan casi cuatro mil dólares hace un
mes mil litros costaban casi dos mil
dólares y nuestros precios se doblan dos
países como india podría mirar hacia
estados unidos y otras naciones para
compensar la falta de aceite pero el
calendario el conflicto dificultará las
cosas para los fabricantes
estadounidenses y los agricultores ni
siquiera empezaron a plantar sus
cultivos previstos para este año y en
medio del éxodo de ucranianos el
gobierno de guatemala informó que
llegaron 12 personas provenientes de
ucrania entre ellos varios menores de
edad que recibirán el estatus de
refugiados se trata de familiares de
trabajadores de la compañía minera
guatemalteca de níquel subsidiaria de la
firma suiza software investment
justamente hace algunos días periodistas
internacionales revelaron que dicha
empresa presuntamente habría sobornado a
funcionarios locales sería responsable
de contaminar ríos en guatemala durante
los últimos años
cambiamos de tema y vamos hasta colombia
donde 38.8 millones de personas están
llamadas a las urnas este 13 de marzo
para las elecciones de las que saldrán
los nuevos integrantes del congreso en
esta fecha también se llevan a cabo
consultas para elegir a los candidatos
presidenciales de 3 coaliciones una
derecha a otra del centro y otra de
izquierda entre los legisladores que
serán elegidos 16 escaños son reservados
para víctimas del conflicto con la
extinta guerrilla de las farc sin
embargo algunos de los aspirantes a
estas sillas denuncian que hay personas
vinculadas con los victimarios que
intentan ganar estos puestos conversamos
con jenny elipa lópez doctora en
estudios políticos y relaciones
internacionales que nos contó más al
respecto
bueno efectivamente lo que ha ocurrido
con las curules de pase está en el marco
de la continuidad de la violencia y de
la violencia digamos de una violencia
generalizada y de la violencia política
entonces si tenemos escenarios no
solamente lo que de lo que usted bien
señala de
candidatos y candidaturas a curules de
paz que están en el marco la
representación de muchas de estas
organizaciones son relacionadas con
organizaciones de victimarios pero
además tenemos la presión y la
imposibilidad de desarrollar el proceso
político de la de las víctimas para
lograr una representación teniendo otro
elemento fundamental y es que las
elecciones las curules de pda's no
solamente van a representar directamente
a las víctimas sino representan por
primera vez en las zonas rurales hay que
recordar que la posibilidad de la
elección de las curules de paz se está
en el marco de la población rural y ese
es otro elemento que está que está
presente y digamos esto que estamos
viviendo demuestra claramente la
continuidad de escenarios de conflicto y
de violencia generalizada en nuestro
país fin del informativo continúen con
nosotros
[Música]